the Chrisleys dealt one last blow God
didn't bring us this far to drop us off
leaving no alternatives for the couple
except surrender to prison next week
these were very serious crimes the fraud
was extensive days ahead of their prison
start date multiple Reports say Todd and
Julie were denied bail so as the
Chrisley Knows Best Stars planned their
appeal they'll need to fight their bank
fraud and tax evasion convictions from
behind bars the reality of it for me is
that when you know you did not do these
things and yet you sit you stand here
convicted that's a hard pill to swallow
and the Stars reportedly requested to
delay their date to surrender that too
was denied they must report to their
Florida prisons on January 17th what we
will not do is we will not break
prosecutors said Todd and Julie took out
30 million dollars in fraudulent bank
loans to fund their lavish lifestyle we
grew up in a very small rural town and
now our main home is 30 000 square feet
this is Michael closet things were
organized by season we signed up for a
show that has entertained millions and
millions and millions of people but what
we didn't sign up for is to be lied on
after their sentencing the couple's
attorney said in a statement Todd and
Julie are people of faith and that Faith
gives them strength as they appeal their
convictions we file for an appeal and by
the grace of God
Our Truth
wins we made a commitment that we were
not going to give up and there's a lot
writing on that appeal the Chrisleys
received a combined 19-year prison
sentence you know one of the things that
the courts are supposed to take into
account when they sentence is the
deterrent effect and when it comes to
things like bank fraud tax evasion and
things that the Chrisleys were convicted
of it's sending a message to the
community at large that these crimes do
not go unpunished yes what we're going
through this storm that we're going
through
it's bad it's tough It's hard it's
hurtful and it and would it be as hard
if the truth was out there no it's
devastating for our family but I had to
look at my kids and say snap out of it
it could be worse as for daughter
Savannah she's ready to press pause on
some major life events until I know that
they're gonna be there yeah I can't get
married I can't have a kid and dad has
told me like when I start feeling bad
for myself dad was like it doesn't if I
may not be here in front of you but I'm
still alive yeah I'm still fighting I'm
still you know you don't have to live a
day without speaking to me exactly I've
never seen two people my parents be so
steadfast in their faith in the end the
truth will prevail may get harder before
it gets easier but we happy
foreign